هذه الدوله يمثلها فعليا نتنياهو حاليا
وهو حريص كل الحرص على البقاء في السلطه
وهناك الكثير ممن قال بان كل القرارات
التي
يتخذها فيها جانب كبير من شخصنه الموضوع
وان يبقى مده طويله وان يستفرد بالحكم في
الوقت الذي كان هناك عدد من الاسرائيليين
اي في وقفه يطالبون برحيل نتنياهو
ومحاسبته كان هو و في غلاف غزه في زياره
قال الجيش الاسرائيلي وقالت الحكومه بانها
كانت لرفع معنويات الجنود الاسرائيليين
هناك كيف استقبل الراي ال العام
الاسرائيلي تلك
الزياره زياره استعراضيه هكذا وصفها
الاعلام الاسرائيلي من جانب اخر لا نريد
ان ننسى بانه منع من الخطابه وهاجمه احد
الجنود وهذه القضيه يعني انتشرت في النار
كالهشيم واعتبرت نوعا ما هزه في صوره
نتنياهو نتنياهو يريد ان يستعرض يعني مساء
السبت خرج في الساعه التاسعه بعد يعني ان
ثبت اليهود وبالعاده لا يوجد تصريحات في
هذا الوقت خرج للاعلام الاسرائيلي ليتحدث
منفردا تساءلت المعارضه الاسرائيليه تساءل
الجمهور الاسرائيلي اين جانتس اين وزير
الجيش اين بقيه القيادات الامنيه لماذا
تخرج وحيدا لانه باختصار نتنياهو الان
يحارب على الصوره يريد ان يعيد الى
الاذهان الاسرائيليه بانه شخصيه تستطيع
قيادتهم الى بر الامان استطلاعات الراي
الداخليه الان تضع نتنياهو في برتبه
متاخره خلف جانس كشخصيه مفضله لقياده
الدوله العبريه الى جانب ذلك حزبه تراجع
كثيرا في استطلاعات الراي بنيامين نتنياهو
الذي ينتظر السجن في النهايه ان لم يتنحى
سياسيا خلال الفتره المقبله هو يريد فعلا
ان يمحو ما حل به خلال السابع من اكتوبر
وهو يعي تماما انه كشخصيه سياسيه استمرت
فتره الفتره الاطول في قياده اسرائيل لا
يريد ان يسجل على اسمه هذه الهزائم
المتلاحقه وبالمجمل ما يمكن قوله نتنياهو
يعيش اللحظات الاسوا في حياته حتى منتخبي
من اليمين باتوا يشعرون بانه بالفعل قاد
اسرائيل الى مكان لم يكن يجب ان تكون فيه